really interesting story out of the
Washington Post this is a report from
Michigan that the Washington Post
reported that Muslims and Christians are
teaming up in Michigan to protest the
creepy LGBT curricula in the schools
so the way the Washington Post reports
it is that this the Christians are the
bad guys and the Muslims were just kind
of duped and brought along for the ride
if you look at the videos by the way it
looks like the Muslims here are actually
leading the show and Muslims are
obviously very very represented because
of mass migration in Michigan and in
Dearborn particular the the they show up
to a Dearborn Public Schools meeting and
they they chant that they want to throw
the bums out because these weirdos in
the schools are trying to trans the kids
and push the rainbow ideology on them
take a listen
vote
[Music]
them out vote them out now as far as I
can tell every single person in that
room is a Muslim I don't I don't see
anyone that looks particularly Christian
uh there at all but the Washington Post
has to frame it they can't frame it as
the Muslims or the bad guys it always
has to be the Christians who are the bad
guys or the white people who are the bad
guys or the men who are the bad guys or
the straight people who are the bad guys
that's the way that their identity
politics works so they say the
Christians are leading this movement
against
LGBT progress and openness and inclusion
in the schools and you know okay yeah
some of the Muslims went along with it
no it's the it's the Muslim I'm sure
Christians back this too I I'll speak as
a Christian I absolutely 100 support
those guys who are in Michigan pushing
back on the LGBT curriculum
but it's the Muslims saying wait a
second we don't want this crap we don't
want you to tell our daughters that
they're secretly boys or vice versa get
this stuff out of the schools
and and what makes the story so
interesting to me
is that this is clearly going to be an
important political Alliance moving
forward and it's a major shift in the
early 2000s after 9 11. you you did not
exactly see the Christians and the
Muslims teaming up in American politics
there was a great threat from radical
Islam the wars that we were fighting
during that period were against radical
Muslims in the Middle East there were
Terror attacks by radical Muslims in the
United States and so you didn't see that
kind of Alliance but now in the year of
Our Lord 2022 the the major threat to
the United States does not seem to be
coming from Al Qaeda which barely exists
anymore Isis or the radical Muslims that
doesn't seem to be the big threat if I
asked you right now what are you most
worried about in terms of threats
against you and your family and
specifically your kids
are you more worried about
some crazy Muslim terrorist somewhere in
the world or are you more worried about
the drag queen who's showing up to your
kids kindergarten classroom it's
obviously going to be the latter and
because that's the threat because the
most immediate threat right now to to
our society is from the radical left
right here at home I think you're going
to see more and more of this kind of an
alliance religious and conservatives
Christians and Muslims and Jews and just
normal people who are even perhaps even
somewhat vague or agnostic in their
religion but they they prefer a kind of
traditional moral order we are all going
to team up together because we have a
common foe right now that threatens the
very fabric of our society and all of
the the beliefs and traditions and and
virtues that we all hold so dear get
ready for for much more of a CR many
more Christian Muslim rallies against
the creeps who are trying to trans your
kids miss tunnels how's my favorite host
of The Daily wire had a question for you
uh regarding a dilemma I have so I have
a friend of mine who is a very big fan
of my band purging sin
and
he is transgender
he basically dresses up in women's
clothing he's on hormones
but he still has his male appendages now
I value his friendship and the fact that
he has been
a huge fan of our band for the longest
time and would really hate to break off
this professional relationship as a
result of difference of views
and to top it all off he's very
conservative pro-trump
so my question to you is in this
situation how would I retain my
friendship with this guy
but at the same time too
Express that I do not believe in what he
believes in shout out to Davies and the
fourth Thursday cigar club
does that slap my base
is that that might be slap my base
that's a great daily wire remember great
Michael Knowles show remember uh
what would I do if I were in your shoes
I would
remain friends with the guy if you can
and just
view that friendship and view him as you
would any other friend who has a mental
illness because it obviously is a mental
illness if you're a man and you think
that you're a woman and you behave that
way I have plenty of friends and family
members with mental illnesses especially
you know I grew up in New York I think
there's a higher disproportion a higher
proportion of mental illnesses in New
York something about the city or
something but I would yeah I would treat
it like you have a friend or a family
member who's bipolar who has I don't
know some kind of mood disorder or or
someone who has schizophrenia or even
you know has transgenderism
I
I'm trying to think if I still have
friends who are transgender I have had
friends who are transgender and some of
whom don't speak to me anymore because
they're very upset that I won't uh
affirm their delusions but I I've never
broken up a friendship because someone
has some weird sexual hang up quite the
opposite I'm I'm always happy to spend
time I've gotten along with Blair white
you know who's in the media and had
Blair on the show and
he and I got along just fine I I always
get get in trouble with a very small
number of people on the right who when
they're trying to attack me they'll
they'll point to a photo I once took a
photo with a transvestite at a big
political convention and
I I
I I think they're very upset that I was
nice to a transvestite guy I thought I
have no reason not to be nice to a
transvestite guy I would never lie to
him and tell him that he's really a
woman I would never uh say that the
society
should tolerate or encourage
transvestitism or transgenderism but I
see no reason to be nice to somebody or
to have a friendship with someone who's
confused I think what's required is a
little bit of humility you know as is
often the case what's required is just a
little bit of humility and recognizing
this is a fallen world and and so you
speak the truth with love and the truth
as far as you can see it and you
recognize that you've got flaws too and
your friends tolerate you for all of
your many flaws and problems and
struggles and and so you should do the
same to other people it does you should
not squish at all you should not call
him by his woman name or whatever you
know or call him she or something but
yeah yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't not be
friends with a guy because he's mentally
ill that seems like the time you should
most be friends with a guy the rest of
the show is continuing now there are uh
fake headlines that we need to
we need to work through today okay this
is Friday on Friday it's fake headline
day Davies picks out five headlines for
a real one is fake I had had a perfect
score
now I don't I got it wrong last week I
need you to help me in the comments
section to pick out which one is the
fake headline
you don't want to miss it if you're not
a member click the link in the
description and join us see you over on
the member block
[Music]
oh
foreign